if you've been following call of duty
behind the scenes you'll know that the
name of this year's title leaked before
last week's official reveal and now even
more details have slipped out I'm Tony
and this is your preemptive gamespot
news update more leaked call of duty
world war two marketing materials list a
Friday November third release date
recent entries in the series have also
released on Friday so this is pretty
believable they also talked about the
games campaign mentioning the likes of
d-day Brotherhood and quote classic call
of duty combat the leaked material also
mentions a second totally different
campaign designed for cooperative play
and on the competitive side multiplayer
will feature quote many of World War
tues most iconic locations with a
private beta for those who pre-order all
of this is unconfirmed by Activision at
this point so make sure you like and
subscribe to be the first to know when
it gets confirmed and you won't have to
wait long to hear more a call of duty
live stream is planned for this
Wednesday april 26th at ten a.m. pacific
1 p.m. eastern and for a deeper look at
war shooters and what they can do you
can check out the latest episode of
reboot
[Music]